salut à vous tous les membres de la team
menthe à l'eau alors je fais la vidéo ce
samedi soir dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche ce qui explique ces jolies sert
pour parler avec vous de 2010 est donc
ce ne sera pas une vidéo à proprement
parler sur mentaliste mais j'aimerais
vraiment que vous regardiez la vidéo
parce que je vais avoir besoin de vous
pour prendre les décisions et je veux
pas faire genre donnez moi votre avis et
en fait j'ai mon plan prédéfini et je
m'en occupe ça va être très important
pour moi et il est temps que je me mette
aussi à travailler pour l'année
prochaine
j'en ai de plus 1er janvier à chaque
fois j'avais une décision à prendre j'en
parlais avec vous et quand on était
moins nombreux j'avais pratiquement tout
le monde qui me répondait là maintenant
c'est différent on est beaucoup plus
nombreux sur la chaîne et de fêtes y en
a déjà qui sont partis cette vidéo parce
que ça les intéresse moins l'avis de la
chaîne en elle-même alors je compte sur
vous dans les commentaires et aux
sondages que je mettrai à la fin pour me
dire ce que vous aimeriez vous et aussi
pourquoi j'ai décidé de faire cette
vidéo sous forme de conversation avec
vous donc j'ai rien écrit de spécial je
vais pas m'amuser à jouer ou à essayer
de vous faire des blagues je vous parle
vraiment comme à des potes filles et
garçons qu'ils seraient là devant moi et
des quiches discuterait il reste donc 76
vidéo avant la fin de l'année donc je
travaille le mental blog comme
d'habitude quotidiennement je suis déjà
en train de travailler sur la vidéo du
31 décembre
et si vous avez suivi vous savez qu'elle
sera doublement spécial 31 décembre que
je passerai sur scène c'était pas prévu
au départ j'ai pas du tout pris
conscience que ce serait là la fin de ce
défi je sais pas sinon j'aurais
peut-être organiser quelque chose
quoique ces 31 personnes auraient été
dispo en pour moi c'est c'est comme ça
et ce sera aussi bien de 2,2 dans un
truc un peu festif commencent à prendre
conscience que ça va faire bizarre
d'arrêter le rythme d'une vidéo par ge
en 2010 est donc je me lancer un nouveau
défi
ça c'est sûr s'établit je sais
exactement lequel ces je vous
l'annoncerai bien sûr à la fin de
l'année toujours en vidéo c'est toujours
en rapport avec le mentalisme c'est
toujours sur youtube mais c'est autre
chose
je pense aussi continuer à faire des
vidéos régulière un petit peu dans le
format mentale vlog pas tous les jours
ça n'aurait pas de sens mais peut-être
une deux trois fois par semaine je me
suis pas encore positionnés là dessus et
je vais découvrir ce que c'est d'avoir
du temps pour bosser plus ces vidéos
pouvoir faire des vidéos un petit peu
plus longue
améliorer les montages vous donner plus
de source en fait approfondir simplement
certains sujets que j'aimerais
approfondir avec vous et puis à côté de
ça il ya quelque chose qui me trotte
dans la tête depuis deux trois semaines
ses rapports aux blogs
bon vous savez que je joue un spectacle
depuis quatre ans et demi que je suis en
train d'écrire le nouveau qui commence
en janvier mais ya pas que ça en fait
qui se passe il ya deux projets disons
qu'ils sont en train de naître soit dans
la réalité soit juste dans mon esprit
pour l'instant avec de certaines envies
et tout ça ça a un rapport avec le
mentalisme à chaque fois mais sa part
rapport direct à 100% avec youtube et
quand j'ai monté le mental blog j'ai mis
une mauvaise blague parce que je voulais
faire développe aussi de toutes ses
activités
et au final le blog c'est ce que je fais
le moins sur la chaîne alors je me dis
est-ce que ça vaudrait pas le coup que
pour 2017 ou même avons tiens d'ailleurs
jeu
projeté 2017 mais ça pourrait être avant
pourquoi je vous dirai pas une chaîne
secondaire qui me permettrait de vous
loguez c'est à dire d'être en permanence
avec ma caméra et de bloguer séquelles à
la construction du spectacle les dates
de tournée et les autres projets aussi à
côté en cours vous savez que je voudrais
m'essayer à écrire un livre
je sais pas si ça sortira un jour mais
je pourrais fils mais aussi les choses
que je fais pour écrire le livre ou
simplement vous parler avoue à la caméra
se serait jamais du blog de vie privée
directement comme une sorte de rendez
vous alors il n'y aurait pas dans mon
idéal il y aurait pas de jour fixe de
sortie il y aura même pas de rythme et
en fait peut-être des fois il y en
aurait beaucoup et des fois il y en
aurait pas durant un moment ce serait
vraiment lié à mes activités et s'il ya
quelque chose à bloguer ou pas ou à
discuter ou pas n'y aurait pas forcément
de gros montage derrière n'y a pas
forcément de grosses contraintes
enfin quand je dis gros montage
évidemment je mettrais que les choses
qui sont intéressantes mais je
chercherai pas à développer cette chaîne
en fait pour tout vous dire j'aurais
j'aurais adoré bloguer ce qui était de
faire ce défi là cette année
c'était marrant en fait j'ai pas du tout
pensé mais d'avoir une espèce de
making-of de en fait c'est quoi
concrètement de devoir faire des vidéos
de la nuit les écrire les montées avant
de se coucher d'être en carence de
sommeil
tu vois tous ces trucs là ça aurait pu
être intéressant de partager avec vous
mais je n'ai pas fait donc cette chaîne
secondaires pourraient aussi pallier à
tout ça et j'aimerais avoir votre avis
dessus est ce que vous trouvez que c'est
une bonne idée
pas une bonne idée est-ce que vous
pensez que non vaut mieux faire ce genre
de choses aussi sur la chaîne mais en
pas trop fréquents est-ce qu'il faut
lancer en 2017 ou en 2016 ou jamais
j'aimerais avoir votre avis là-dessus
votre avis également sur le fait de
l'année prochaine continuer à faire un
petit peu du contenu similaire de
mentalisme sur le mental blog mais
peut-être une fois par semaine ou
plusieurs fois par semaine enfin voila
j'aimerais avoir vos avis sur tout ça et
vous inquiétez pas pour le défi je me
donne pour 2017
ça je vous le dirai plus tard je ne sais
plus ce que j'étais en train de dire
parce que je viens d'avoir un problème
avec ma carte sd ça fait une heure et
demie une heure trente que j'ai c'est de
réparer le problème et toutes mes cartes
sd bref j'ai enfin réussi je vais pas
vous mentir c'est la journée la plus
dure pour moi de toute l'année pour
faire la vidéo tout cet état de fatigue
qui fait que là je commence à péter les
plombs je vous ai posé plein de
questions
répondez-moi dans les commentaires je
vous mets un sondage également pour
savoir ce que vous pensez
de cette chaîne secondaire oui non c'est
une très mauvaise idée fabien hausse et
un coup de génie
c'est vous qui me dit c'est vous qui
voyez merci d'être là j'ai hâte d'être
demain pour écrire une vidéo plus
dynamiques dirons-nous aller passer un
bon dimanche rendez vous demain en
pleine forme à 17h ciao